all right we're here with cass and ted
philpott and elle
um who they recently um have been
upgrading their home room by room but
can't agree to do the same thing in the
final room macau what advice do you give
couples actually when it comes to design
they live in the same space but they
want different things what do you do
okay so this is what i say like treating
a design is just like a marriage it's
got to be some compromise right so i
really think that you know one more than
one person in the room than the other so
i recommend doing a mood board you take
three inspirational images you take
inspirational images you put them all on
that one board and you can at least
begin to see what your design style is
mood boards are key all right mikhail
and i have taken all the evidence into
consideration and come to a decision
here is what the room currently looks
like photos please everybody there we go
all right oh
by the way the
dog right well michelle and i um have
the final verdict are you ready to see
everything um that we've done and
knowing when you look at it every single
item in the room um has to go back to
the store so if you don't
you don't like it it's not a problem
sounds fair i'm just kidding everything
in the room is yours every single item
everything
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so ladies why don't you two ladies take
a seat here
and my friend since you really wanted an
entertainment uh area i'm gonna let you
hang out over here so you can get a
little more comfortable that sounds
great
okay
the chairs are on swivels something that
we found very key because you've got
your tv here so if everybody wants to
watch great if everybody wants to make
this coffee table like for food or games
or center point then you have
the swivel action this pottery barn farm
armchair like it has a swivel it's just
amazing and it gives me like a little
conversational pit right yeah also
they've they've
really camouflaged the swivel they you
don't these do not look like swivels but
they have that surprise in them so you
know wherever you are and then we did a
little bar over here
because you could have like sandwiches
and like coca-cola's with your friends
you could have a beer with your friends
you can have a cocktail with your
friends and just like instead of it
looking kind of like a cheesy bar we
wanted it to be very neutral and chic
well and then the other thing you know
one thing that you love more so than
anything is storage but you have like a
ton of storage like you guys can house
all of your your games i mean it's just
so much trolls posters and remote
controls they can start to muck up the
room so just slide them in your leather
boxes and for all that stuff that you
want to be like nothing to see here
because life is messy it's real and so
you got to have somewhere to cram all
that stuff
and hide it
[Music]
but
also this speaks to i think the number
one thing that really jumped out at us
this week in design week the number one
trend is that pops of black
are extremely chic you have a little
black coffee table a little black stripe
in the rug a black table little art
so
cass what do you think i
i'm speechless this is so inspired it
will give me a space
and it also gives them it it really does
mesh both of our visions i think
good job
what do you think i love it i love it
and i think my friends will too i think
we can hang out in here it'll be rad all
right ted thoughts truthfully i love it
i might even take up reading
look at that yeah
well ted we have one more surprise for
you and the whole family so as you
picture the room this is one giant
window you had a couch in front of it
but what we wanted to do since we got
rid of the couch was we gave you this
amazing incredible shuffle board
game to place in the road
it is so chic it goes right with the
wood and the furniture
i have to say like oh my gosh you knew
you wanted a game oh and it gets better
my friend so
with this beautiful shuffleboard you're
gonna need to take some type of score as
you're whipping up on these ladies so
i've created a diy uh scoreboard for you
that you'll be able to take home so that
you and the family can keep score while
you're playing awesome thank you
oh my goodness that is so amazing okay
what is like one word that comes to mind
when you look at the room cass inspired
l amazing
ted a blend fantastic
[Applause]
and we could not have done this without
pottery barn oh my god you are the dream
makers that made it happen
[Music]
you